أجنبي
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير للجميع، اسمي وأنا
سعيد جدًا ويشرفني أن أكون
معكم بعد ظهر هذا اليوم، العرض التقديمي
أو الحديث الذي سأقدمه بعنوان
التكنولوجيا ومستقبل ممارسة طب الأسنان، لقد
تدربت لأصبح طبيب أسنان في
المنتصف  التسعينات وخلال تلك الفترة لم يكن
لدينا عروض PowerPoint التقديمية أو كان
محدودًا حقًا ولم يستخدمه جميع الأساتذة، فقد
اعتدنا أن يكون لدينا أجهزة عرض علوية
تحتوي على شرائح مرسومة باليد أو
مكتوبة بخط اليد، هل يعرف أي منكم
ما هو جهاز عرض علوي
ليس حقًا  ليس كثيرًا، لذا أنتم يا رفاق
أصغر سنًا مما كنت أعتقد، لذا فإن
جهاز العرض العلوي هو شيء يبدو
هكذا، حسنًا، لذلك كان هذا الشيء
بدائيًا ومحدودًا حقًا ولم
ينقل الرسالة بسهولة حقًا، مما
جعل التعلم والتدريس
صعبًا في الوقت الحاضر وبسبب ذلك  بالنسبة للتكنولوجيا،
تختلف الأمور كثيرًا الآن حيث
يمكن لطلابنا مشاهدة مقاطع الفيديو على YouTube
بدلاً من الاضطرار إلى الجلوس حول
الأستاذ لمشاهدته وهو يشرح على
سن صغير، ويمكن للأستاذ أيضًا تقديم
العرض التوضيحي والحصول على كاميرا تصور
ما يفعله وكيف يتم ذلك  يتم عرضه على
الشاشة ويمكن للطلاب
مشاهدته بسهولة حقًا والانتباه
إلى أنواع مختلفة من التفاصيل، وقد جعلت هذه
التطورات التكنولوجية كما قلت
التدريس والتعلم
أسهل بكثير حقًا الآن،
ولم يتم فصل طب الأسنان عن كل هذه
التطورات التكنولوجية التي أحدثتها
ثورة في ممارسة طب الأسنان
أتذكر عندما تخرجت في عام 1999،
تم تدريبي باستخدام نفس المعدات
التي تم تدريب والدي عليها خلال
الستينيات والسبعينيات من القرن الماضي
ولكن بتصميم مختلف قليلاً،
دعنا نقول ولكن المعدات كانت في
الأساس هي  نفس الشيء ولكن بعد ذلك وخلال
2000 عام اتخذت الأمور
منظورًا مختلفًا وأحدثت
التطورات التكنولوجية
ثورة في ممارسة طب الأسنان دعنا
نقول تقنيات جديدة ومواد جديدة
وأساليب جديدة
يمكن رؤية التقدم التكنولوجي في طب الأسنان في تشخيص
وعلاج طب الأسنان  يُصدر تصميم
وتنفيذ إجراءات طب الأسنان المختلفة
والانتقال من
التقنيات التقليدية إلى
البدائل التكنولوجية الأكثر حداثة، كما أحدث
ثورة في أبحاث طب الأسنان
والتي تساعد أيضًا في تطوير
مهنة طب الأسنان وممارسة طب الأسنان،
وسأبدأ بالشيء البسيط وهو
استخدام الكاميرا داخل الفم
على الرغم من أن هذه
التطورات التكنولوجية ليست متاحة على نطاق واسع حتى الآن
في جميع عيادات أو مؤسسات طب الأسنان
لأنها لا تزال
ذات تكلفة عالية ولكنها
جعلت ممارسة طب الأسنان
أسهل بكثير ونحن نأمل ونتطلع إلى
ذلك  ستنخفض الأسعار في
المستقبل القريب وستصبح
متاحة على نطاق واسع في جميع
ممارسات ومؤسسات طب الأسنان دعنا نعود
إلى ما بدأناه بالكاميرا داخل الفم،
الكاميرا داخل الفم هي
جهاز صغير يمكن لطبيب الأسنان استخدامه
داخل فم المريض  وهذه
الكاميرا داخل الفم ستظهر للمريض
على شاشة الكمبيوتر أمامه
المشاكل التي يعاني منها مع أسنانه
ولثته والعلاج الذي
يود طبيب الأسنان أن
يشرح للمريض
إجراء الأسنان الذي سيقوم به و  كما
يمكن للمريض متابعة أه
التقدم في علاج الأسنان الذي
يقدمه له
طبيب الأسنان أيضا طريقة أخرى للتشخيص
شهدت
ثورة هي
التصوير الشعاعي داخل الأسنان في الماضي كنا نقوم بعمل
الصور الشعاعية  باستخدام هذه الأفلام،
تكون هذه الأفلام أرخص بكثير مما نستخدمه
هذه الأيام، ولكن الإجراء
أكثر صعوبة لأنه سيتعين عليك
وضع الفيلم، وأخذ الصورة الشعاعية، وأخذ
الفيلم إلى غرفة مظلمة ثم معالجته،
ثم يستغرق الأمر حوالي خمسة إلى  سبع
دقائق حتى تتمكن من معرفة ما إذا
كانت الأشعة السينية الخاصة بك صحيحة وما إذا كنت قد
التقطت التفاصيل المطلوبة وما
إذا كانت تتمتع بالحدة التي
تريدها على عكس
أجهزة الاستشعار الشعاعية الرقمية حيث
تضعها داخل فم المريض
تأخذ الصورة الشعاعية ومن ثم يتم
عرضها مباشرة على الشاشة، وتكون
الأشعة السينية حادة جدًا ومحددة جيدًا
والتفاصيل تظهر بشكل جيد جدًا
على الشاشة، يمكنك تكبيرها، يمكنك
تصغيرها، يمكنك إجراء جميع أنواع
القياسات على ذلك  لذلك فقد جعل
التشخيص أسهل بكثير وأسرع، ومن
ثم فإن التعرض للأشعة السينية
أقل بكثير من الصور الشعاعية التي
استخدمناها من قبل، لذا فهي أقل
خطورة بكثير على المريض وطبيب الأسنان
أيضًا، إلا أنها تحتوي على بعض المخاطر  العيوب
وأولها، مثل جميع
التطورات التكنولوجية الأخرى، فهو
أكثر تكلفة بكثير حيث أن المستشعر الرقمي قد
يتسبب في بضعة آلاف من دينار
أردني، أما مجموعة كاملة من الأفلام القديمة فقد تتسبب في
ربما 10 دينار أردني أو شيء من هذا القبيل وفي
بعض الأحيان قد تحتاج إلى أكثر من
حجم واحد للمستشعر لتتمكن من استخدامه في
أجزاء مختلفة من الفم، كما أن
هذا المستشعر مصنوع من البلاستيك الصلب، لذلك في
بعض الأحيان لا يكون قابلاً للتكيف بسهولة مع
جميع أجزاء تجويف الفم، وهو
تقدم آخر في التصوير الشعاعي للأسنان
والذي ساعد أيضًا في
التشخيص السهل وتنفيذ
إجراءات طب الأسنان هو
شيء نسميه
التصوير المقطعي بالكمبيوتر وهو نوع خاص من الأشعة المقطعية،
وأعتقد أنكم جميعًا سمعتم عن
الأشعة المقطعية، لذا فهو يأخذ أجزاء
وصورة ثلاثية الأبعاد للأمر برمته.  يظهر
تفاصيل أكثر للأسنان
والأنسجة المحيطة بها وأه العظام
أيضًا بدلاً من وجود صورة ثنائية الأبعاد
لهياكل الفم
ويستخدم في الوقت الحاضر على نطاق واسع في
علاجات قناة الجذر وأيضًا في تخطيط
وتنفيذ أنواع مختلفة من
العمليات الجراحية مثل  استخراج ضرس
العقل وتخطيط
زراعة الأسنان لأنه يتيح لنا كما
قلنا الحصول على صورة ثلاثية الأبعاد مفصلة ودقيقة
مع إشعاع أقل من
المدن العادية وكما نرى هنا
يمكننا إجراء بعض القياسات
لارتفاع العظام أيضًا  كما يوضح لنا أيضًا
عرض العظام هنا والذي لا يمكن
رؤيته في الصور الشعاعية العادية، لذا فهذه
أداة جيدة جدًا أو
أداة تشخيصية ولكن مرة أخرى، فإن
الصورة الشعاعية العادية أكثر تكلفة حيث
سيكلف المريض دفع 10 دينار أردني
بينما هذا  قد يصل سعر الواحد إلى 50 دينارًا
وهو غير متوفر على نطاق واسع في عيادة طب الأسنان
وفي مراكز التصوير الشعاعي
أيضًا لذا فهو لا يزال محدودًا
الآن ننتقل إلى مثال آخر وهو
حقًا مجال خبرتي لأنه
تخصصي وهو أه
الثابت  والتعويضات السنية القابلة للإزالة،
أعتقد أنكم جميعًا تعرفون ما هو التاج أو
الجسر، إما أن يكون لديك واحدًا أو
تذهب مع والديك أو مع
أصدقائك إلى طبيب أسنان للحصول على واحد، لذلك
في الماضي
عندما تذهب إلى طبيب الأسنان
تذهب و  خذ طبيب الأسنان لينتهي من
تحضير أسنانك ثم سيبدأ
بأخذ طبعة لأسنانك،
حسنًا للحصول على نسخة طبق الأصل سلبية والتي
سيتم إرسالها لاحقًا إلى المختبر وتصب
في نموذج ومن ثم سيتم
العمل على النموذج من قبل فني الأسنان  من
سيبدأ بخلط المواد
ثم بناء الطرف الاصطناعي ثم
خبزه وإنهاءه وإرساله مرة أخرى
إلى طبيب الأسنان ليضعه داخل
فم المريض، ويسمى هذا الإجراء
بسير العمل اليدوي ولا يزال
يستخدم على نطاق واسع في المؤسسات
والعيادات.  حتى طلابنا يتعلمون
استخدامه في الجامعة
الأردنية ولكن على عكس هذا حيث
تأتي الكثير من الأخطاء أثناء
أخذ الانطباع
وصبه في المختبر والذي يعتمد
بشكل كبير أيضًا على المهارات اليدوية للمهندسين.
فنيًا، لدينا شيء أحدث آخر
يزحف أيضًا إلى
مهنة طب الأسنان ويبدأ في
الاستخدام أكثر فأكثر وهو
سير العمل الرقمي مرة أخرى، نعود إلى هذه
الكاميرا داخل الفم والتي يمكنها التقاط
نفس الانطباع الذي كنا نتحدث
عنه من قبل و  يتم عرضه على
الشاشة كما نرى هنا،
حسنًا، وهذا يعادل
الانطباع في سير العمل اليدوي،
لذا فهو يأخذ تفاصيل الأسنان
والهياكل المحيطة
وبعد الانتهاء من ذلك نرسل
هذا إلى مختبرنا  سيكون لديه
نفس البرنامج، وسيبدأ في بناء
الطرف الاصطناعي على البرنامج
وهذا ما يسمى التصميم بمساعدة الكمبيوتر،
والتصنيع بمساعدة الكمبيوتر أو كما
نسميها في طب الأسنان
تقنية كاميرا القط أو سير العمل الرقمي، فهو
يسمح لنا بالحصول على
طرف صناعي دقيق حقًا  وكما قلت، فهو يستخدم
الانطباعات والنماذج الرقمية الآن
ينظر إليها المختبر وهو يصمم
الطرف الاصطناعي وقد أرسله إلينا عبر
البريد الإلكتروني أو Whatsapp أو أي شيء
يمكن لطبيب الأسنان أن ينظر إليه على الطرف الاصطناعي النهائي
الحجم والشكل واللون
وكل شيء  يمكنه التأكد من أن
كل شيء على ما يرام ثم
يرسل المختبر هذا إلى آلة طحن أو
آلة طباعة تقوم بعمل
الطرف الاصطناعي بالكامل ثم يخرجونه من
الآلة ويرسلونه إلى
طبيب الأسنان حتى لا يشارك أي إنسان في
ذلك  إنها لا تعتمد على
المهارات أو القدرات الفنية للبشر، لذلك لدينا
أخطاء أقل في ذلك وتركيبات صناعية أكثر دقة
مرة أخرى، وهذه
طريقة رائعة جدًا لإجراء التيجان والجسور
ولكنها ليست متاحة على نطاق واسع
لأن الكاميرا داخل الفم ستتسبب أيضًا في
حوالي 15 ألفًا  أو شيء من هذا القبيل
إلى جانب البرنامج ولا يزال
يقتصر على عيادات معينة ومختبرات معينة
وما زلنا نعتمد أكثر على
سير العمل اليدوي ولكن أعتقد أنه
في المستقبل القريب ستتحول الأمور إلى سير
العمل الرقمي وستنخفض الأسعار
مثل كل شيء آخر في  في العالم
مثل الأسعار تبدأ مرتفعة ثم
تبدأ في الانخفاض لأنها بدأت
تصبح متاحة على نطاق واسع للجميع،
ومثال آخر أيضًا هو استخدام
الليزر، وقد أدى استخدام الليزر أيضًا
إلى أه ممارسة طب الأسنان، حيث
أصبحت الجراحة أسهل بكثير وأكثر ملاءمة
يستخدم على نطاق واسع لدى المرضى في
جراحات اللثة وتبييض الأسنان
وإزالة البكتيريا وعلاجات قناة الأسنان
وأيضًا في أخذ الخزعات
فهي أقل توغلاً وأكثر راحة
للمريض وأكثر دقة مرة أخرى فإن
الساحل مرتفع قليلاً ولكن
تلك الليزرات  تستخدم على نطاق واسع أكثر من
التقنيات الأخرى مثل كاميرا القطة
كما تحدثت عنها منذ
قليل، فهي تستخدم أكثر من
كاميرا القطة في العمليات الجراحية ومن قبل أطباء الأسنان في
الواقع الافتراضي،
لذا أراهن أنكم جميعًا تعرفون عن
الواقع الافتراضي أفضل مني.  يتم
استخدامه أيضًا في طب الأسنان، فهو عبارة عن إنشاء
محاكاة تفاعلية ومن المفيد
إظهار المريض أو محاكاة
الإجراء للمريض لتقليل
قلقه، كما أنها طريقة
يمكن للطلاب من خلالها تدريب وممارسة
إجراءات طب الأسنان بطريقة خاضعة للرقابة
وبيئة آمنة للأسف،
الواقع الافتراضي لطب الأسنان غير متوفر
في الأردن حتى الآن، كما أنه غير
متوفر على نطاق واسع في
العالم أجمع، فهو يقتصر فقط على
المؤسسات وتدريس طلاب طب الأسنان،
كل هذا
بسبب التكلفة المرتفعة بالطبع.  هذه
التقنية
وأخيرًا وليس آخرًا سأتحدث
أيضًا عن الذكاء الاصطناعي، فأنت
أيضًا أكثر دراية
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وكيف يعمل أكثر مني،
لكنه في الوقت الحاضر حقق نجاحًا كبيرًا في
طب الأسنان ويستخدم على نطاق واسع في
أبحاث الأسنان ويحظى بشعبية كبيرة.  هناك الكثير من الاستشهادات
للنشر، لذلك يخبرني أي شخص مهتم بأن
لدي فكرة وأنا
أعمل على ذلك،
لذلك يستخدم خوارزميات لتحليل
معلومات المريض ويمكنه اكتشاف الأنماط
وتحديد المشكلات المحتملة عادةً
ما نستخدمه هو الصور الفوتوغرافية والأشعة السينية أو
تاريخ المرضى
الآن بالنسبة للصور الفوتوغرافية، كان هناك الكثير
من الأبحاث حول التقاط صور
من داخل تجويف الفم للمرضى الذين يعانون من أنسجة
طبيعية قبل سرطانية وأنسجة فموية،
وهذا أفضل
في الواقع من أخذ الخزعات لأنه
أقل تدخلاً ولا يسبب
إزعاجًا للمريض وأحيانًا  داخل
تجويف الفم يمكن للعين البشرية أن
تفوت تفاصيل معينة في بعض الأحيان لا نستطيع
التمييز بين الأنسجة الطبيعية
وأنسجة الفم الخبيثة ولكن بالنسبة
للذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يفعله وفي
كثير من الحالات فهو
بدقة عالية يمكننا استخدامه أيضًا في طب الأسنان
التصوير الشعاعي في الكشف عن
تسوس الأسنان أو الآفات المحيطة بالذروة، كما
أنه يستخدم أيضًا في تقويم الأسنان
وفي علاج اللثة وفي الكثير من تخصصات طب الأسنان
في الوقت الحاضر وكما أخبرتك، فإن
بعضًا منها يعد نجاحًا كبيرًا للبحث
في الوقت الحاضر لأبحاث طب الأسنان،
لذا  نعلم جميعًا أن المستقبل هو
للتكنولوجيا وأنها تشق
طريقها إلى ممارسة طب الأسنان
ونأمل أن تنخفض الأسعار حتى
نتمكن من استخدامها على
قاعدة أوسع مما نفعله هذه الأيام ونشكركم
جميعًا على الاستماع